your local polling station will be open
from 7am to 10 p.m on polling day you
can find details of your polling station
on your poll card or on the where I live
page on our website
when you arrive at your polling station
signs and our helpful staff will show
you where to go
you don't need your pole card to vote
but you will need to give your name and
address
[Music]
you'll also need to show your accepted
form of photo ID such as a passport or
driving license
[Music]
or instead your voter Authority
certificate
you will not be able to vote without it
[Music]
you will be given one ballot paper to
vote in the local election
depending on where you live you may be
given another for your Parish Council
privacy screens will be available for
those that need them
please read and follow the instructions
given on the ballot paper and in the
polling booth
you can bring your own pen or pencil but
pencils will be available in the polling
Booth if needed
Mark the ballot paper clearly following
the instructions
[Music]
there will be one Ballot Box for the
local election place your ballot paper
in this box if there is a parish
election in your area there will be a
second Ballot Box and that's it
thanks for using your vault
[Music]